Next wednesday, we're
having David Swensen, uh,
lecture to us,
uh,
and he heads up the Yale and dam or
the investment of the Yale endowment.
Uh, and, uh, I have, uh, a New
York Times article on the syllabus,
just like sort of a biography of him. You
could read on reserve. I have his, uh,
uh, his recent books. Uh,
so I hope that you will get
a lot from him. Uh, he, uh,
I misspoke. He's not a Yale
College graduate. He's a yell.
He can omics phd is undergraduate,
was from University of Wisconsin.
Um, but he's been at Yale
for a very long time.
He came to Yale from Wall Street in 1985.
And at that time, the Yale endowment
was worth about $1 billion.
Uh,
it,
it is now under his
leadership 22.5 billion.
Uh, and that, that, uh, that,
that explains a lot of
the quality of your life.
Um, because that means we have
about $2 million per student.
Uh, and the interest on $2
million is a, what is that? Uh,
a hundred. I can't even do division. About
a hundred thousand dollars a year. Uh,
and so that's why a Yale is more,
much more generous with financial aid
than other universities and why we have
beautiful Chris. This room was
built, I believe in the 30s.
I don't think David Swensen for this room,
but for a lot of other things.
Uh, so, uh,
Yale I had a 28% return on
its portfolio last year,
which was number one of
all college endowments. Uh,
moreover it had a 17.8% average
return for the last 10 years,
which is number one among
a university endowments.
Um, we beat Harvard, we
beat France, but actually,
uh,
Princeton was the head of the Princeton
endowment is a protege of David Swensen.
Uh, and I'm sure that these
people get together and talk.
All of the major university Harvard
has been doing very well too.
And so has a Duke Mit Amhurst a
lot of it seems that universities,
uh, managed to invest very well. Uh,
at least they have in recent decades.
I think that has my theory,
that has something to do with
the intellectual atmosphere
at universities that,
uh,
investing well in
requires a careful study.
And the intellectual tradition
we have at universities, uh,
helps promote the, so, uh,
I dunno if David Swinson can continue
to do this. I think we're, uh,
he's had a spectacular return,
but he's getting into a challenging year.
This is a year of financial crises,
so I'm warning you ahead that don't expect
a 28% return and the yell portfolio,
uh, for the coming year. Um,
you can ask him about that.
I don't know if he can do it again
in this car and this situation.
That will be amazing. Uh, okay.
So that, that would be next Wednesday.
So, um, meanwhile, uh, I wanted to,
uh, talk today about
regulation. Uh, and, uh,
wow.
I think we're all right.
Um, yeah, something needs
more regulation here.
I think so, uh, all these wires.
So,
uh,
I wanted to motivate regulation in terms
of the last lecture that our previous
lecture was about behavioral finance
and it was about human failings.
Uh, and I think that, uh,
we motivate a lot of our regulation of
financial markets by the kinds of errors
that people make. And I
wanted to list a few, uh,
uh, a few errors that are
well known, uh, and that,
uh, are exploited by unscrupulous
people in finance. Uh,
and so I think they motivate a
lot of what a regular itself.
I'm going to write a number of principles
of behavioral finance down and just
mention them briefly and then
we'll turn to regulation.
So,
uh,
these are things from
the field of psychology,
wishful thinking. This refers
to the fact that people, uh,
this sounds like something
you probably already know how,
but it's been documented by psychologist.
People tend to make the air of
believing what they want to believe.
All right. Uh, so for example, uh,
people tend to believe
that their team will win.
This has been documented by psychologist.
They have a bias. If you ask them,
what's the probability that Yale
or when the Yale Harvard game, uh,
don't expect ELL students
or Harvard students to give
a, by unbiased probability,
you tend to in your mind think
that you're going to win. Uh,
and this also applies to elections
and we just had a primary,
uh, uh, yesterday. People tend to assume
that the candidate that they believe in,
we'll win.
So it's well known and this is
something that can be exploited by,
uh, people selling investments. Uh,
second thing,
attention anomalies,
um,
uh,
these are a
human attention,
tends to be sporadic.
Uh, that is that you,
the errors that people naturally
make are often errors of inattention.
You'll look at certain
things and you overly, uh,
you pay too much attention to some
things and too little to others. Um,
this is, uh, uh,
this is something that psychologists have
been talking about for over a hundred
years. Uh, human attention is
part of human intelligence.
We have to know what to pay attention
to and people have who are not good and
focusing their attention
on the right things.
And that talking just about attention
deficit disorder and talking about some
more high level question of how you know,
what you should be paying attention to.
Uh, and, uh,
under attention there's a
social basis for attention.
And that is that people tend to pay
attention to what other people are paying
attention to. And so, uh, uh,
it's easy to sweep things under the rug
and get people to forget something. Uh,
the kinds of things that are naturally
talked about yet excessive attention and
the details tend to get forgotten.
Uh,
three is anchoring.
This refers to a,
uh,
a tendency for people in
making quantitative judgements
to subconsciously have
their judgments anchored
by some arbitrary stimulus.
Uh, and I mentioned
overconfidence last period.
We then tend to have overconfidence
in our anchor judgments.
Uh, so, um, the, the,
the classic experiment that demonstrated
anchoring was caught on an diverse,
I'm writing k and t a and a
wheel of fortune experiment,
which they did in 1974.
Uh,
what they did is they, uh, they,
they got subjects to participate
in a psychological experiment.
And the experiment consisted of
asking the subjects questions that had
quantitative answers, which were
always numbers from zero to 100.
Uh,
and then they said,
I want to ask you a question about
before you answered the question,
I'm going to spin a wheel of fortune.
You know, he, you know, the wheel of,
it's like one of those
things on quiz shows.
If you spin this big wheel that rotates
for awhile and then it stops at one
number,
obviously a random number because this
wheel of fortune head all the numbers
from zero to a hundred. Okay? So
one of the questions they asked was,
what percent of African nations
belong to the United Nations? Okay.
And,
uh,
that apparently is a difficult question
that most people didn't know in 1974.
But they were, they did it. They said,
we'll ask you the question and think
about while you're thinking about it,
don't answer yet.
We're going to spin this wheel of fortune.
And so it comes up with a random number.
Okay. Then they ask for the answer. Well,
it turns out that people tended to give
an answer close to the number that came
up on the wheel of fortune. All right? Now
they perfectly well knew that the real,
real unfortunate was random.
Uh, so, uh, the experimenters,
after they got the number, they say, hey,
your number is almost the same as
the number that just came up, uh,
and people with. And he said, did you
just give me the number that came off?
And FIFA would deny it. They would say,
oh no, I wasn't influenced by that number.
The point of anchoring is that you are
subconsciously influenced by numbers,
uh, and that it affects your
judgment. You think, you know.
So for example,
in looking at a stock part,
if you ask people to predict
a stock market price,
they think of some number
that they saw before, uh,
and they are overly influenced
by that number. So for example,
if in the late 1990s you
were to ask a question,
I'm hypothesizing, ah,
how likely is that the,
is that the Dow will be over 10,000 by,
by the year 2008.
Uh,
people might give that a low probability
because it had never been over 10,000.
And so they just had no psychological
anchoring on that number. Um,
so, uh, but once it passes 2000,
then it seems completely natural.
And that's anchoring related
to this is, um, the, uh,
representativeness heuristic.
I can't even write this this long.
We're representativeness heuristic.
It seems to me that if you type this,
you'll get a spellcheck error.
Okay.
And that's kind of an first ski again.
Uh,
and it's related to anchoring in
some sense. What it means is that,
uh,
it refers to a human tendency to judge
events on the basis of similarity to
other events that are prominent in our,
in our mind without regard to the
actual probability of the event.
Uh, I'll give you a, and one of
condiment and diversity is examples.
People were asked, uh, to, uh,
judge the occupation of a young woman,
and it had a description of the young
woman and the woman was described as
sensitive, artistic,
et cetera. Uh, and, uh,
then the occupation that they were
allowed where bank teller sculptress or
something else. All right. Uh,
many people chose sculptress
because they thought, well,
if she's a sensitive artistic
woman, maybe she's a sculptress. Uh,
but that is a, uh, uh,
a terrible mistake because we should
know that sculptress is a very rare,
very few people have the job
of a sculptress or a sculptor.
Um, and so, uh, it's a mistake.
So what it means is that people,
well, gosh, and being caught here,
what it means is that that's the
stuff, that's why I ran my pocket. Uh,
what it means is that,
uh,
we sometimes exaggerate in our imagination
some rare event and it colors our
thinking. Uh, so for example,
the stock market crash of 1929 is
repeatedly re expected even though it only
happened once,
but it's just a prominent in our thinking.
And people are looking at stock prices
to see patterns that they remember that
are prominent in their thinking.
And then those patterns, uh,
are given an exaggerated probability.
Uh, so when we looked at the random walk,
the series,
I think the representativeness heuristic
played a role in there as well.
When you're,
when you look at a random walk,
you have the intuitive impression
that you can extrapolate it,
but it doesn't look like you
can't believe. It's really random.
But the reason you can't is because you
overweight the probability of certain,
uh, things that caught your attention. Um,
okay. So, um, there's some Maura,
uh,
so a
five is gambling behaviors.
Anthropologists have found that,
uh,
gambling is present in all human cultures.
Not that everyone gambles,
but,
uh,
there will be you go to any human society
and ask about it and there will be
some game of chance that
they play that, uh, uh,
that influences their thinking.
So, uh, the problem with,
uh,
there's a problem with gambling behavior
because in a certain fraction of the
population, we have
pathological gambling. Uh,
one study estimated that 1.1% of men
and a half a percent of women for some
reason,
more common among men than women,
but in both sexes are
pathological gamblers.
That means it's like alcoholism.
They cannot control themselves
and it ruins their lives.
They get divorces because the spouse
compliance that, you know, my,
my husband or wife gambled away the,
all of her money and dad,
but they can't stop themselves.
There's an organization called
gamblers anonymous, uh, which helps.
It's like alcoholics anonymous. It helps
people who are really in trouble. Uh,
and this is a problem.
Now.
I think the financial industry
attracts people like that.
And so your overrepresented, if people
who are not quite pathological, uh,
people who are stimulated
somehow by chance, uh,
uh, and, uh, that is a, um, uh,
a problem, uh, magical thinking.
Uh,
this refers,
this actually goes back to
BF. Skinner, a psychologist,
uh,
Hu
were asked in the first
half of this century,
I actually had him as a next door neighbor
is a strange thing. I was visiting, uh,
uh,
Harvard and MIT in Cambridge and I rented
a house and this guy was next door.
And he and I both used to walk
into work together, not together.
I never really met him, but I always
felt an affinity with him. Now,
he must've died 20 years ago
now. But anyway, he did it.
Famous experiment, uh, with
pigeons, uh, which, uh,
in the 1940s, uh, uh, 1948, uh,
in which he induced strange
behavior patterns in pigeons
by the following simple
experiment.
The experiment was the,
he would put the pigeon was in a cage,
okay.
And he'd let the pigeon get pretty
hungry, okay. And hungry pigeon.
And so not happy patients.
And then he had a machine that granted
each pigeon one piece of corn every 15
seconds. Okay. Uh,
and so that's very frustratingly slow for
a hungry pigeon. They get it, a feast,
one piece every 15 seconds.
And then he observed through time,
uh, after subjecting pigeons
to this torture for some time,
they might be not approved by,
it's not really torture.
It's like dieting or something. You all
lived through that, right? But, uh, stem,
I torture for a vigil.
He noticed that the pigeons were,
it started behaving in
strange ways. So, uh,
and he kept them separate so they
couldn't learn from each other. Uh,
one patient was jumping up and down a lot,
and another one was bobbing it's head.
And another one was doing
a kind of a little dance.
And what he concluded was these pigeons
were trying to figure out what makes
those pieces of corn calm. And
they started to think, well,
he had to get the interval between corns,
right to make this work. But he started,
the pigeons started to
think effectively that,
what was it I did just before
that last piece of corn came,
I was bobbing my head. So maybe I'd
better Bob my head again. And sure enough,
another piece of corn comes and they
start assuming that what they were doing,
uh, is making the corn calm. Uh, and so,
but each one does a different thing.
So if they're all in isolation,
they would all be doing different things.
But I think our financial markets
are like that, that people,
they develop some investment strategy
and through pure chance it does well,
but they, because of overconfidence
and magical thinking,
it starts to go to their ego.
They think I'm really a smart investor.
I've figured it out. Uh, and uh,
it can reinforce the behavior,
uh, uh, until they get to
maybe some terrible end.
And that doesn't necessarily
work out as well.
Bf Skinner's never let his pigeons starve
and they all made it out. All right?
Uh, there's something else
called quasi magical thinking.
Uh,
which was a term coined many years
later by a Eldar Shafir year.
Uh, and Amos touristy shall fear.
Here's a young,
uh,
psychologist out of Princeton who
teamed up with the old psychologist,
Tversky, uh, and wrote this paper. Um,
uh, and what it refers to is, uh, uh,
people,
uh,
get the impression that
they can control randomness.
Maybe the patients were thinking
that maybe not, we don't know,
a chauffeur and Torsky referred
experiments with people,
not Fijians. Okay. And
quasi magical thinking is a,
a, an illusion, that big document,
it occurs regularly and people,
uh,
which they might deny if asked about,
but there's an illusion that I can
control randomness to my willpower or my,
uh,
I won't talk about their experiments,
but I just want to mention
one by a Harvard psychologist,
Ellen Langer. I mentioned
this before, but I,
I think I mentioned it
before. Uh, if you say,
I want to ask you to bet on a coin toss,
I,
there's two different ways of doing it.
One is to say how much,
how much will you bet?
And then I tossed the coin the other
way as I tossed the coin first and I can
see the outcome. And then I asked
how much would you like to bet?
And Langer found that people want to
bet more if the coin hasn't been tossed
yet. Okay, why would that
be? Why would you care?
It's still the same experiment.
It appears that people
at some think that they,
they can exert willpower
over it and control it. Uh,
and this gives rise again to
overconfidence among investors.
It's also another example
which is relevant.
I don't know if any of you voted
yesterday. Um, why do people vote?
Because economic theory would say
that nobody ever votes if we're all a
conventional economic theory says we're
all relentlessly selfish and calculating,
right? Isn't that what you've
learned in economics? And so, uh,
well maybe you didn't necessarily,
but that is a canonical theory.
But if you're relentlessly selfish
and calculating, you would say, um,
the chances that I decide
the election or zero. Right?
And so I just don't, I know that's
not going to bother. The question is,
you must have thought that,
right?
You know that you're not going
to decide the election. Uh,
and so what does it matter?
And so if you can introspect
and ask why is it that I vote,
I think that at least for many of us,
there is a,
there is a sort of logical conundrum
we go through and that is a,
if good people don't vote, then
we'll be in a bad world. Okay?
And so I have to vote to
approve that good people vote.
And then maybe it will happen.
If I'm a good person,
then other people will be good person.
All right? This is magical thinking. Uh,
and it,
uh,
it affects people because it gives them
a sense of confidence and power, uh,
over events that are thought
to be random or uncontrollable.
Uh, so, uh,
it can also be something
that can be exploited by,
uh, by, uh, some not so nice people.
Okay.
I wanted to talk about a regulation
that the problem with finance is that,
uh, it's a beautiful financial
institutions are beautiful structures,
uh, but they only, uh,
are as good as the people
who use them. And so, uh,
the problem is that history of finance
is the history of a lot of people.
Uh,
a lot of people being
exploited and treated badly.
So,
uh,
there's temptations of the market that,
people who,
uh,
no human psychology now that they
can exploit human weaknesses.
Uh,
and so there's a temptation to oversell
a investments that is promised that they
will do well. Uh, you see this all the
time. I was just seeing yesterdays paper.
Someone was selling gold coins, one of
the, you know, don't buy gold coins that,
you know, that, right? But there were
words in there. They said, of course,
we cannot guarantee that they
won't go up in value, but, uh,
but historically they have always
done it or something like that.
They're trying to oversell,
you know,
that buying gold coins from some newspaper
ad is not a smart investment. Um,
but that they know that there will
be people out there. Uh, you know,
recent example of overselling the
National Association of Realtors has been
running ads saying that home prices
have always doubled every 10 years.
Uh, they, they didn't do it.
They didn't work that they put it in the
present tense home prices double every
10 years.
So that's an organization of people
who sell real estate and they have ad
campaigns trying to convince you
that home prices are going to double.
That's overselling because we're
in a real estate crisis in home,
prices are falling. Uh, and, uh,
that's the kind of thing that
make some people upset. Uh,
there's a tendency to hide information.
Uh, you, you, you avoid telling people
the things that would discourage them.
People have attention anomalies,
so they don't go out and see all
the information and you, you, if,
if you don't put it up front,
then they'll never find it.
Uh,
there's a tendency for loyalty to friends.
That's your own friends.
Uh, and there's this word,
other people I think different languages
have different, uh, you know, there's,
there's friends and then there's all
those random people that we don't care
about. Uh, and so, uh,
investors will have a tendency to
try to hide it from people who sell
investments.
We'll try to channel the good investments
to their friends and take her, uh,
and,
and dump the bad stuff on other people.
That's what's been happening a little
more than a little bit in the subprime
crisis.
So we've managed to package subprime
loans that we thought some people thought
were terrible and sell them
off to a unwitting foreigners.
I didn't know they thought that
they were getting good stuff. Uh,
there's also a tendency for
churning for commissions.
Uh, this is, uh,
of of fault that real
estate brokers can make a,
if they're paid by
commission on each trade,
they just keep calling you up and coming
up with new ideas for new trades. Uh,
and so, uh, that's unethical
behavior, uh, because it,
uh, uh, because if you,
if you keep trading too much,
then you cannot possibly make money.
The trading commissions will eat up all
of your profits and professionals know
that. So it's, it's bad behavior.
So we have, uh,
historically developed, uh,
regulation regulations that deal with,
um,
with these problems.
The only reason,
reason I believe that we have financial
markets that work is because we have the
regulations.
So I'm going to talk primarily
about us regulations, uh,
and uh,
give a little history of it.
But the U S is actually an important
country for regulation because, uh,
it has been a model for much of
the regulations around the world.
So,
uh,
I need to give a kind of a history of
financial regulations in the United
States. Uh, it makes it
rather a simple story.
And the simple story is that regulation,
uh,
mostly came in with the progressive era,
um,
at the beginning of the century,
uh,
and reached its culmination at
the time of the Great Depression,
uh, and set up a lot of institutions
that are still with us today.
And then there was deregulation,
which started in around the 1970s. Uh,
and the events we've seen,
whether that we're seeing today is a
outcome of both the regulation and the
deregulation. So, uh, I
wanted to start out with,
uh, the origins of
securities regulation. Uh,
a critical point was a book
written by Louis Brandeis.
Uh, that's the guy that Brandeis
university is named after.
He was an author and lawyer
then Supreme Court justice. Uh,
but he wrote a book in 1914,
uh,
called other people's money.
And, uh, it was very influential.
I have it on reserve,
but that's not required for the midterm
results if you're interested to see it.
Uh, and, uh, uh,
he believed that, uh,
the most important step,
uh,
for the government in promoting better
financial markets is disclosure to force,
uh,
to force businesses or
financial businesses to
disclose the truth equally to
everybody. Uh, and, uh,
his famous quote is,
sunshine is the best disinfectant.
Sunshine meaning the truth. And, uh,
everyone in the financial industry has
to just tell people what they're doing.
Uh,
and he said it has to be really disclosed.
And he likened it to a
labeling. They were already, uh,
in 1914 starting to require that a
food packages would show nutritional or
ingredients and nutritional information.
Uh,
I was on the package and he thought
that's the kind of model for the financial
industry.
The disclosure has to be made convenient
so that it's not like you can get the
information by going downtown to
city hall and asking for it. So the,
the principle is that you have to require
that the information be given to the
investor. So that was a very
important, um, so in, uh,
around the time of this book,
state regulators were, um,
developing, uh, at the state
government level and the United States,
uh,
what they call blue sky laws.
Okay.
These were laws regulating
how securities are sold. Uh,
and it was different theories about
why they call it on blue sky laws.
I think it was because people
were overselling investments
and saying there's no
limit to this investment, but
the blue sky above, uh, so,
uh,
the problem with the blue sky laws is
that they were each state done separately
and it was hard for states to
manage what we're basically,
um, national businesses.
So the blue sky lives,
we're basically coming in and the teens
and the 1920s things changed because the
telephone first became wide,
widely spread, uh, until the,
until around that, until the teens,
telephones were very expensive because
they didn't have a good amplification
technology. But by the tiny is everybody
got a telephone in their house. Um,
and the average person made
hundreds of phone calls a year.
So it was a big change in our society.
And this led to the, uh, boiler rooms.
And if you know that,
uh, the so called born,
these were businesses that
called her on the telephone.
And so the stock often bogus stocks,
uh,
in the 1920s. The reason they
call them boiler rooms is, uh,
if you are,
I'm selling stocks by telephone,
there's no reason to rent a nice
office. Right? So you get the cheapest.
So you put a whole bank of telephones
in the cheapest place and that would be
the basement of some building
where they have the boiler.
And so you'd have a whole bunch of people
selling securities down there and it
could vacate quickly if the
authorities challenge you. Uh, so,
uh, uh, in the 1920s, a
lot of bogus stuff was,
so a lot of people were cheated.
Uh,
and so after the stock
market crash of 1929,
it led to and Movement for regulation.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
the most important thing was the
1934 foundation of the securities.
Yeah.
And Exchange Commission,
r s e c,
uh, which I think ultimately, um,
dates back to really the embodiment
of Louis Brandeis principles. So,
uh, this, uh, securities and
exchange commission was a,
a,
an organization that I guess you say it's,
it's principle structure.
It's principle thing was to make sure that
disclosure was proper and that people,
uh,
were found it easy to get the
information about securities.
Uh,
and the SEC
was very controversial at first because
it was seen as interfering with business.
And the u s has been
built on principles of,
of individual freedom and this seem
like unnecessary government intrusion.
Uh, so there was a hostile attitude
between business and the original sec,
uh,
Franklin Delano Roosevelt was viewed as
very left wing by business and very, uh,
uh, uh, contrary to American values.
But in fact,
the SCC promoted the very free
market concepts that were,
um, that were widely
believed in, in this country.
Uh, basically what it did is it made
it feel that people won't get cheated.
Uh, and so, uh, the sec
was a strong regulator,
uh, and it, uh, uh,
it really did it restore confidence in
the financial markets in this country.
Other countries in Europe
after the 1929 crash,
they had a different reaction to the
scandals and problems of the twenties,
and it wasn't as favorable.
The markets is in the u
s with the Securities and
Exchange Commission from the
beginning had it as its mission to
make a financial markets work properly.
Uh, and that is a wonderful story. So, uh,
one of the first
chairman of the Sec,
uh,
was
a man named William O.
Douglas.
Uh,
uh,
was actually a Yale law professor.
Uh, I guess he influences me,
uh, because, um, I have, I have
on the reading list, again,
it's an optional reading, uh, but, uh,
he has a book called
democracy and Finance
1940.
Uh, and, uh, what he advocated again,
is that financial markets have to
be made to work for, uh, the people.
Uh, I guess this influenced me. Uh,
you actually am I 2003
book new financial load,
or I talked about the democratization
of finance as a fundamental principle.
We have to make finance work
for real people. And so for me,
that not understanding human frailties
and understanding human psychology to
make things work.
Uh,
he was also a major figure
in the legal realism.
Um, uh, school, which was a represented,
recognized,
uh,
human failings and human behavior
and establishment of laws.
We have to realize that people
don't read all the fine print, uh,
and don't understand if you
have a precisely written
contract in legal language,
maybe they don't get it.
Uh,
one of the things that came out,
uh,
and it was firmly embodied into
law with the advent of the sec,
there were pre precursors to this,
but the FCC enforces the difference
between public and private securities.
This is a very important distinction.
Uh,
public securities are
securities that the sec doc,
uh, uh, um, we'll, uh,
except as suitable for the general public
and private securities or securities
that have not been vetted by
the sec for the general public.
So, uh, uh,
the sec, uh, you have to decide,
you don't hear about public
companies and private companies.
If you're a public company,
it means that you've gone through the
procedure that the sec to be approved as a
public company.
If you are a public company,
the important thing is you have to
do all of the disclosure that, uh,
Louis Brandeis would have like.
So you have to file regular forms
with the SEC disclosing information,
uh, public companies and
these public companies.
If you want to get on the sec website,
uh,
go to sec.gov and then as,
there is a
tab that you can click,
which is Edgar. Uh, and uh,
if you click on Edgar,
you can enter the name of any public
company in the United States. Uh,
and then all of its filings are online
and you can find out incredible amount of
information about companies.
Uh,
it's all there as long as they're
public companies. Uh, so public,
a lot of companies don't want to be
public because you can't keep secrets very
well.
You've got to regularly put those things
up online and they're out there for
everybody to see.
Um,
so why do companies can choose
whether to be public or private?
Why do they choose to be
public? Well, they, it's a
balancing. They have to balance.
Sometimes they don't like the
choice they made, but, uh, the,
the advantage to being public is that
people trust you more and more over your
market is bigger. Uh, and, and, uh,
so public companies have
an advantage. So, uh,
companies don't like to
be public. Generally. It's
contrary to their instincts.
We keep all sorts of
secrets in our company.
We don't want to be filing all of our
information all the time and having it go
right up on the website,
on standard forms so that
everyone can easily process it.
Uh,
but they,
they may swallow their doubts because
they have a sense that it will improve the
market for their shares.
So we have a lot of public companies.
Um, now if you are a public
or a private company,
uh, you are limited to, uh, what,
uh,
where you can sell your investments.
Uh,
and let's talk an example of, of, uh,
important kind of private company.
It's called a hedge fund.
Okay.
If you are, this is not, this
is a private investment company.
Uh, let's, let's think before
we talk about head. Think
of, suppose you're right.
Public Investment Company,
uh, approved by the SEC.
The problem with being a public investment
company is you have to file quarterly
reports about all the things you've
invested in. I mean, and so you say,
how can I make money beating the
market if every quarter I have to tell
everybody what I'm doing?
Uh,
and so a lot of investment
companies don't want to be public.
They want to be private,
so they don't have to hedge funds do
not post their investments and Edgar,
and so they're private.
Um,
but if you're a private company,
you're subject to regulation that
limits a lot of things you can do.
Notably, you're not
allowed to advertise. Uh,
if you're a hedge fund,
you're not for the public,
you're not approved for
investing by the public.
So what business do you have
to put buy ads in newspapers,
announcing yourself as a
result? Hedge funds, uh,
are, have a very low profile.
It's not their choice. They
might like to advertise,
but they can't without running
a foul of the sec. They'll say,
you're behaving like a public
company and you're not public. Uh,
and so hedge funds do not advertise and
that's why people don't know about them.
And they have a mysterious, uh, uh, they,
they sound mysterious. Um, but
moreover, very significantly,
uh, they're, uh,
they are limited in what
kind of investors can take a,
now there's different kinds of hedge fund.
Th there's a lot of legal
complexity here, but, uh,
a three c one hedge farm,
uh,
is limited to 99 and investors.
Yeah.
Uh, and that's not very many people. Uh,
and they must be accredited investors.
And so you asked what is an
accredited investor? Well,
if you want to find out,
you can get onto a sec.gov and it
will give you the current definition.
So I wonder how many of you
are accredited investors?
I would guess not many of you. Here's
how you become an accredited investor.
A, you have $1 million
in investible. Yeah.
That's not including your house.
Is it? An investible assets? Okay.
Uh, I won't ask for a show
of, I don't want any to,
you're making at least
$200,000 a year, uh, or, uh,
you, uh, if you're married, you have to
be the couple of making at least 300,000.
Uh, so, um,
it's supposed to be a fun for rich people.
It's done.
They haven't raised the definitions of
accredited investors for many years. So,
uh, last year, the SEC, uh, put
out a proposal that, uh, you know,
it's getting too easy to be
an accredited investor. Uh,
and so they put out a proposal
that we raised the, uh,
wealth level to 2.5 million. Okay. Uh,
and I thought they were going to,
and that was to protect
people who might be naive,
innocent people who only have $1 million.
They're only half $2 million and
don't know what they're doing, uh,
from hedge funds. But, uh, it got
shot down apparently, cause it never,
never happened.
I think it's very hard to raise the
definition of accredited investors because
in that you do that,
you're closing large numbers of people
out from her ability to invest in hedge
funds and they don't like that.
They feel insulted.
So there was a lot of angry reaction.
Uh,
there's also another kind of
hedge fund, three c seven, uh,
which can take 500 investors.
Uh,
if they, if they register as a three
c seven, they can take more investors,
but then they're limited
to qualified purchasers.
And this just an example
of their regulations. Uh,
and a qualified purchaser a has
to have at least $5 million,
uh, or if it's an institution
at least 25 million,
um,
that is a natural person.
A natural person refers to a human being.
Uh,
so it's 5 million for natural,
uh,
and 25 million for institutions.
So if you're a small college with
only 20 million in a portfolio,
you don't come across as
a qualified purchases.
They're trying to protect innocent small
colleges who only have $20 million.
The idea is that people who don't have
much money can't afford expensive lawyers
and they can't figure it out and they
really shouldn't be investing in hedge
funds. Uh, so that is the, uh,
uh,
these,
these are public, private,
uh, uh, distinctions are,
anarchists are offensive to
some people because it, it's,
it seems like the government is acting
like a parent and most of the people are,
if you're not accredited as an investor,
it's like the government doesn't
respect you. Uh, right. I mean,
it's like they're treating
you like children.
Why would it be that somebody else
is allowed to invest in a hedge fund?
And I'm not, uh, so, uh,
it rankles but on the other hand,
these regulations survive because the
reality is that people are victimized all
the time and uh,
uh,
we can't just allow companies
to act in secrecy. I,
this is something that I believe and not
everyone believes in this, uh, but, um,
the general principle has
been now ever since the 1930s,
that the general public is not allowed
to invest in things that are not properly
documented.
Another important distinction
and securities regulation is the
distinction between insider and outsider.
And insider is someone who is privy to
the secret information of a company.
Uh, and um, uh, the, uh,
secret information could
be used to trade, right?
If you know the secrets of a
company, if you know some, uh,
good news about the company
before the public does,
you could buy the shares
in the company and,
and experienced that the
profit when the price goes up,
you would be exploding insider
information and you'd be victimizing the
outsiders.
Uh,
so the idea from the
beginning at the sec was that,
uh,
insiders should not be allowed
to trade on information that is,
uh, that is not properly
disclosed to the public. Um,
and, uh, but especially there
was an important change. Um,
regulation FD,
I came in in 2000 FTE stands
for full disclosure. This is a,
uh,
sec regulation,
a regulation FD,
uh,
was I think past and reg in
recognition of the internet under,
uh, uh, Louis Brandeis.
Brandeis wanted companies to
always present the information,
but for him it always met
presenting a document.
So they had something called a prospectus.
For example,
you could not sell a security without
giving a prospectus to the potential
buyers. And the prospectus would
be something approved by the sec.
Uh, and I don't know if the
word is approved, but it's a,
you have to run it by the sec and
then you always have to give that up.
But he was living in a paper age.
We now live in the Internet age.
Uh,
and so regulation FD and now I don't know
if it actually mentions the internet,
but it's, it's, uh,
tends to the regulation FD basically
says that whenever a company announces
information,
it has to be announced a available almost
instantly to everybody in the market.
And so the way it has worked out
in practice is that companies,
when they have a major
announcement to make,
they have some kind of web
event and anybody in the world,
they would be notified and they can
get on and hear it as it's happening.
So we kind of have meetings,
big meetings on the web for a
disclosure of important information.
Uh, and so, uh, uh,
this has made it very clear
then there's a, there has to be,
if you announced anything,
you have to announce it all at once on
a certain day and you can't have favored
people that you give the announcement too.
Uh,
so market surveillance is the fastest that
dark exchanges and other organizations
do to make sure that inside information
is not being, uh, uh,
is not being mishandled.
And so the,
the self regulatory organizations SROC,
um,
which are industry organizations
that regulate the industry,
that's an American way of doing things
rather than have the government, uh,
regulate.
We have an industry organization that
does it so that the government doesn't
have to, uh, the SRO is,
have complex regulatory equipment,
computers that can discuss
this discover, um, uh,
in insider trading. And, uh, the SRO is,
uh, we'll catch you or they
may catch you if, if you try.
So I wanted to give you an
example of SRO behavior. Uh,
and this is just one news story.
Um,
it was in 1995,
uh,
a secretary at Ibm Corporation,
was asked to xerox some documents by
her boss and the documents described a
proposed takeover of Lotus Corporation.
I remember Laura say that was the,
uh,
corporation that produced the
first thread sheet program.
It's now been replaced
mostly by at Microsoft Excel,
but at the time it was big.
Okay. So this was big news.
Ibm is going to take over at
Lotus or try to take over Lotus.
And, uh, we now know what
happened because of the, uh,
the surveillance investigation.
Uh,
she told her husband that she
adjusts xerox to this thing about,
she'd read what she was xeroxing
and she told her husband,
who is a beeper salesman about the news.
Uh,
he did nothing except tell
two friends than story.
He didn't buy show.
He just told two friends.
My wife says that IBM is
going to take over a lotus.
The friends immediately
bought a lotus shares. Uh,
and uh, uh, then, uh, uh,
that was June two. By June
five, 25 people had bought,
had a half a million
dollars to buy on this tip.
They included a pizza chef and
electrical engineer, uh, bank executive,
a dairy wholesaler, a school
teacher, and for stockbrokers,
stockbrokers get the word
faster. Uh, just what happened.
Those people are all in trouble because
it's illegal to trade on insider
information and they tracked
them all down. And, uh,
uh, uh, so, uh, I give
you another example. Uh,
and this is the example of,
uh, uh, emulex corporate.
Maybe this isn't exactly an insider
trading. This is more fraud. But,
uh, in what year was, this? Was
around sometime in the late nineties.
Uh, Marc Jacob, uh, uh, his name,
he's a guy, he's the criminal here.
He's probably out of jail now.
Marc Jacob, uh, was upset with,
he had done an employee of
Emulex, uh, and, uh, uh, had,
uh, had access to inside
information of the company. Uh,
and so he, I guess he
was involved in the, um,
in the dissemination of
information for the company.
He kind of knew how they did press
releases. So he sent out a fic he bought,
he shorted the company and he, uh, the
stock in the company and he bought a,
he put out a fake press release,
uh,
saying that there was bad news
for the company. Uh, and, uh,
he knew how to make it look like
one of the Mbox press releases. Um,
he also did it from the El
Camino community college
library because he thought
I'd be careful.
I want issue this fake press release on
my own computer because they might be
able to track me back to my own computer.
So he went to this community college and
got one of their library computers and
issue the press release there. He got
picked up by all the major news services.
A stock plummeted. He's sold
immediately and he made a lot of money.
But the problem is it didn't
work. They, they, they,
they track back who sold it, who had
shorted and who had sold just before,
just at that time. And they also, um,
they went back to the El Camino Community
College Library and they interviewed
the librarians and tried to ask them,
do you remember somebody coming here
that didn't look like a student?
And they identified him and so he
was caught. So that's what, uh,
what surveillance does.
They make markets work because
if you didn't have this,
they would be all kinds of, there
would be all kinds of, uh, uh,
crooks and, uh, a bad, a bad actors. Uh,
and uh, the thing about these
organizations is that they
cost money and they cost
nuisances.
A lot of people in the financial community
are annoyed by them because of these
regulations are costly
to comply with. And, uh,
they take a lot of resources, but, uh,
I think enlightened view is that
these things are absolutely essential,
uh, and to trust in the market. Um,
another form of, uh, uh, of, uh,
regulation is accounting regulation.
So for example,
we have, uh, in the United
States, the financial accounting
standards board,
this right here in Connecticut.
All right?
Faas B.
This is not a government organization.
Uh, it was organized, uh,
uh, by the sec in 1973. Uh,
but the sec didn't want to do this job.
They wanted it to be done privately. Uh,
so what FASP does for the United States
is it creates what are called generally
accepted as a g generally
accepted accounting practices.
Uh,
their rules for how an IT company
should keep its books so that, uh,
uh,
so that there's some regularity and
standards and how accounting is done.
Uh, and so when, when, uh,
the financial accounting standards board
to what corporations are saying and,
uh, and helps them, uh, uh, it,
it adjusts the standards
from time to time,
but it does have definitions
that have to be maintained.
Uh, and, um, so a company has a, uh, uh,
a profit and loss statement and
there is something that, uh,
it's called net income,
which is a measure of how much the
company is making the, the, uh,
the profits after expenses of the
company called the bottom line.
Uh, and, uh,
the gap standards are defined.
This is also operating income.
Uh,
now companies can use other definitions
of other accounting standards besides
these.
Uh,
and some of these other definitions
which are not always gap,
other standards
and are widely used in the
industry are other kinds of,
they have what's called core earnings,
uh,
pro forma earnings,
uh, Ebitda, which is earnings,
uh, uh, earnings before interest, taxes,
depreciation and Amortization,
uh, adjusted earnings.
There's all kinds of different
definitions. And so, uh, uh,
companies like to do it their own way
cause they weren't a present themselves in
the best way to the public, but, uh,
they're not allowed to just do it their
own way. They have to do it according to,
uh, uh, standards. Uh,
and so the gap accounting is standardized.
So what a,
what a company can do is present
things in two different ways.
Uh, uh, they,
they can present it gap and
then that goes to Edgar or,
and they can also present it any
other way they liked. But the law, uh,
the SCC requires that they at least
present the standard earnings, uh,
definitions for, um, for all these things.
Now another, um, let,
let me just mention a off balance
sheet accounting. Uh, the, uh,
one thing that the SEC requires that
companies file is there balance sheet,
uh, which you can look up
for any company. And Edgar,
uh,
the balance sheet
of a company has two columns.
It has assets
and it has liabilities.
Uh,
and so on one side is everything that
company owns and the other side is
everything the company
owes. Okay. Uh, and the, uh,
uh,
the,
the net worth of the company is their
assets minus their liabilities. Uh,
and that represents
the value that the company has if they
paid off all their liabilities. Uh,
what the SEC has to worry
about is something called
off balance sheet account.
Hey,
uh,
which occurs when companies
try to hide some of the,
uh, things that they, the,
the liabilities they have,
but not recording them on the
balance sheet. Uh, and, uh,
if you can get away with that,
then you can do, uh, you,
you can conceal maybe some risky
investments you've made or some,
uh, leverage that you've had. Uh,
you might've bought investments
in something by borrowing money.
And so the investment,
the combined investment and liability,
it could be very volatile.
You don't want people to know that,
so you don't put it on the
balance sheet. Uh, so, uh,
the sec and other regulators
have to watch for this.
The classic example of a
company that did this, uh,
it's a classic now was
Enron Corporation. Um, and,
uh,
they had a number of partnerships
that they put on, uh,
as off balance sheet.
So they weren't making risky investments,
but they weren't reporting it
properly on, uh, on the, uh,
SCC forums. And so people didn't
know how risky, uh, how risky.
And Ron was. Uh, more
recently we, uh, this is,
it came out last year,
uh, the sieves, alright,
phone called structured
investment vehicles.
Uh,
we're used by banks to
cover up investments.
They had often in risky subprime loans
where they created special entities
called sibs. Uh, and, uh,
the sieves would be borrowing money
on the commercial paper market to buy
subprime loans. Uh, and, uh, they were,
uh,
in a very risky position because subprime
loans were already recognized as being
risky and they borrowed to buy them,
sell off the value of the subprime loans
went down just a little bit. The, uh,
the sieve would be in trouble.
Uh, and so in the Civ contract,
there was some language that implied
that if the sieve ever went bankrupt,
the bank would come back and rescue them.
And so the say of really was a liability,
but it wasn't visible to,
to investors who are
investing in the back.
So this is another example of off balance
sheet accounting. That was frustrating.
Um, the rules of the SEC. Um,
I wanted to talk about, uh, the, um,
uh,
another,
another instance of regulation that
is important in the United States,
but it's very poorly known.
Uh,
we have something called civic.
that's the securities
and investor
protection corporation,
which was created in 1970 a.
And this is the securities
analog of the FDA. I see.
In banking, uh, I don't
know if I mentioned,
I assume you know about the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation.
I thought that was better known or, well,
let me just mention it by analogy. Uh,
in 1934,
after the failure was,
it was actually created by
Congress in 1933 and, uh,
uh,
went into business in 34 f the,
I see Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation.
So I'll put it down as 1934
guaranteed for a small depositors,
uh, the, uh,
savings deposits they have at a bank.
And that was to protect depositors.
Uh, in the case of bank failure.
And it was a very important innovation
because at that time there were huge runs
on banks.
People were pulling money out of banks
because they feared that if the bank
failed, then they would lose their money.
And so it created a huge crisis in 1933.
So it's,
but it's for a small investors because
currently the limit and the sec,
uh, it's $100,000, right?
So that's not a lot of money.
Um, and whenever you think
of it as a lot of money,
but it's not, uh, if someone
saving for their retirement,
you better have a lot more than that.
$100,000 is only a few years in comment,
even for lower income
people. But at least, uh,
we want to protect the small investors in
the saving in bags. So actually if you,
if you, if you have more than a hundred
thousand dollars in a bank account,
you should probably pull it out and spread
it around over several banks because
each bank is separately insured.
So there's effectively no limit if
you're just a little bit smart, uh,
and you move your accounts
around. Uh, so we had,
so we had deposit insurance, uh, until,
uh, starting in the Great Depression.
And that's been very important. Uh,
and it's now in every country. Uh,
uh,
so we had a run on a bank in the UK.
Uh,
it was called Northern
Rock, uh, last year. Um,
and it turns out that there was a
failure of the UK deposit insurance.
I would say it's a failure because a U K
deposit insurance insured northern rock
only for the first 3000
pounds, uh, up completely.
And then for the next, I forget how many
thousand pounds you were, 90% insured. Uh,
so that was not good enough because
people were worried about losing 10% of
their deposits.
And so there was a big
bank run and northern rock
would've failed if the Bank of
England hadn't come by to rescue them.
Uh,
so I think these deposit insurance
are very important, but we don't,
we didn't have anything for
a corresponding accounts
at brokerage services until
1970. Uh, and, uh, it, uh,
this was motivated by a
spectacular failure of a brokerage,
good body, uh, in, uh, in company, um,
in 1970.
I hope. You know what I mean?
A brokerage service is a,
is a place where a stockbrokers work and
it stockbroker is somebody that manages
your buying and selling of shares. All
right? And so if you want to buy stock,
you can call a stockbroker.
Uh,
like Merrill Lynch is a big retail
broker and they're right down here on the
green. You can go there and say, I want
to buy stocks. And the broker will say,
fine, we'll set up an account for
you. You deposit money in our account.
Now he's not a bank.
He's a broker.
Will have set up a cash account and a
securities account, put some money in,
and then you think about it and
then you call me up and say,
do you want to buy some
stocks? Uh, then I'll,
I'll take money out of your cash account
and I'll put it in these securities.
That's a broker. Okay, good
body and company was a broker,
but it failed in 1970.
It went bankrupt.
And then it looked like the people who
had money and shares and then we'd lose.
Uh, there's two things. You can
have a cash account with them.
You put money into the cash account and
you haven't bought shares with it yet,
it's just sitting here.
It's like in a bank. Um,
you could lose that because good body
and company is going bankrupt, right?
It doesn't have it anymore.
And what about your shares?
Where are good body and
company is supposed to have
your shares, right? But they,
they, they, they generally hold
them in what's called street name.
And that means good body and company
owns the shares and you just have a
contractual relationship with
good body that in principle,
some of those shares are yours.
Um,
but the company that you're investing
in ultimately doesn't have your money.
It's, it's good body that they're
dealing with, although they have ways of,
for proxy and their ways of
finding out who, who's who.
But the problem is if your
brokerage fee for from fails,
you could lose a lot.
You could lose your cash account
and your security account. So, uh,
civic was set up in 1970 a and civic,
uh,
insurance cash accounts up to $100,000
and, uh, securities
accounts up to 500,000.
And so, uh, that's another
example of government, uh,
involvement, uh, in, uh,
as a civic was set up by an
act of Congress. Uh, and, uh,
so, uh, the, um,
unfortunately, I don't know
if you've ever heard of civic.
Most people don't even know it exists.
Uh,
civic did a survey of the U
s population. Uh, and, uh,
this is one of the, in 2001, this is
one of the questions civic asked. Um,
the response were asked to identify the
organization that insures you against
losing money in the stock market or
as the result of investment fraud.
Uh, only 16% of investors knew
that there is no such company.
They make me. It's clear.
SIPOC does not. If you,
if you invest in some
stock and it does badly,
you can't go to civic and say,
Hey, I, my stocks went down,
but please give me my money
back. Uh, they won't do it.
And Moreover, if you say this
stockbroker, he was lying to me.
He told me that this was a good investment
and he even lied and said something
to get me roped in.
They won't pay you back.
The only thing that civic does is
replaced securities. In other words,
if you had an account at a brokerage and
you thought you had a hundred shares of
IBM and now the broker is going bankrupt
and the broker won't answer your email
anymore and it's just gone, you
go to civic and say, I, you know,
I had these a hundred chairs civic
then returns a hundred shares to you.
They don't pay you.
Can they give you the hundred shares?
And that's all they do. Uh,
so you might say that we,
our regulation hasn't gone far enough
and I think maybe it hasn't gone far
enough. Uh, we protect certain kinds of
things and people have to pay attention.
W the, it's a difficult problem
that not everyone is smart.
They vary in their ability.
So we try to make a world in which,
uh, it's pretty safe for the small
investor who's not paying attention,
but it's never perfect and we can't
figure out yet a way to make it perfect.
And we still have four small investors
who are defrauded, who are treated badly,
and the subprime crisis as an example,
some people were treated badly
in this recent financial crisis.
So we just have to keep improving our
regulation and trying to make it a deal
with all of the problems as they come up.
The problems are complex because we're
trying to make a system in which people
are able to make their own decisions as
much as possible and to make them in a
way that, uh, in an
environment that they trust,
but it's just too complicated and too,
it's impossible to make it work perfectly.
All right, so that will conclude this
lecture. So us, I won't be here Monday,
but I'll, I, TA's will, uh,
will handle the exam and I'll,
I'll see you on Wednesday.